.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Es ist extrem bitter ...
... und einfach erschreckend ...
... den eigenen Kindern
nicht zu ihren Grundrechten
verhelfen zu können.
Also ...
Dieser Zustand,
dass die Kinder zwei Jahre
quasi als Halbwaisen leben müssen,
unfreiwillig ...
Stellen Sie sich vor,
die Kinder würden das schon
begreifen und das selber einordnen.
Die würden sich selbst
auch an den Kopf greifen.
Es ist unmöglich.
Peter Schlagmüller, 43,
reist nach Russland,
um nach zwei Jahren Funkstille
seine Söhne wiederzusehen.
Seine Frau hat sie nach der Trennung
mit nach St. Petersburg genommen.
Hier verliert sich ihre Spur.
Peter Schlagmüller hofft verzweifelt,
dass René und André,
heute sechs und vier Jahre alt,
bald wieder auftauchen.
Keine Antwort. Nichts.
Nichts.
Hm. Mein Gott, ey.
Es ist der 24. Dezember 2019,
nachmittags.
Alle anderen
sind längst nach Hause gegangen.
Peter Schlagmüller nicht.
Denn ihn
erwarten traurige Weihnachten.
In einer leeren Wohnung,
ohne seine Kinder.
Es ist krass, was momentan abgeht.
Es ist ... ja, existenziell.
Das Einzige, was ich hier habe,
ist mein Job, der mir die Ablenkung
und Zufriedenheit gibt,
die ich momentan habe.
So kann man das zusammenfassen.
Er trennte sich, möchte aber
nicht weiter auf die Gründe eingehen.
Dass er das alleinige Sorgerecht für
seine Söhne bekam, nützt ihm wenig,
denn seine Frau
ist nach sieben Jahren Ehe
in ihrer Heimat Russland
untergetaucht -
zusammen mit den Kindern.
Das war vor einem Jahr.
Seither wohnt Schlagmüller in einer
kleinen Mansardenwohnung nahe Zürich
und hofft, doch noch zu seinem Recht
zu kommen, d.h., zu seinen Kindern.
Es sieht momentan
noch nicht so eingerichtet aus,
aber wenn sie dann hier sind, werde
ich das mit Hochdruck fertig machen.
Wieso haben Sie es
noch nicht fertig eingerichtet?
Das ist genau der Punkt, der mich
emotional weit runterziehen würde:
wenn ich das
jetzt fertig machen würde
und die Kinder
nicht zurückkommen würden.
Das würde mich
in ein extremes Loch runterziehen.
Darum ist es noch nicht bereit.
Schlafzimmer.
Beide Kinder
brauchen den Papi sicher,
wenn sie in der Nacht
z.B. mal erschrecken.
Ich hatte das früher öfters.
Da musste ich nachts aufstehen.
Die Mutter
konnte keine Unterstützung bieten.
Das war hart,
aber ich habe es gemacht.
Ich hoffe, dass meine Jungs
das noch in Erinnerung haben.
Ich werde immer für sie da sein,
wenn sie ein Problem haben.
Seine spätere Frau lernte er
vor zwölf Jahren im Internet kennen.
Einen Ausdruck ihres damaligen
Profilbildes hat er aufbewahrt.
In was haben Sie sich
bei Ihrer Frau verliebt?
Es war die Sympathie, die Offenheit.
Man konnte über ...
... gängige Themen diskutieren.
Zukunftspläne:
Was ist einem wichtig?
Was weniger?
Internationale Ausprägung.
Sprachgewandtheit.
Das waren so Impacts,
die mich überzeugt haben.
Sie, 28, war im Personalwesen tätig,
er, 32, Kadermann
in einer Gemeindeverwaltung.
Nach zwei Jahren holte er sie
aus Russland in die Schweiz
und heiratete sie.
Weitere drei Jahre später
kam das erste Kind.
Kinder zu kriegen ist schon
ein Einschnitt in das Leben,
das auch die Beziehung grundlegend
in ein anderes Format stellt.
Aber ich gehe grundsätzlich
davon aus bzw. dachte ...
... dass die Kinder eine Stabilität,
eine Konsolidierung bringen,
eine Bestätigung davon,
was man vorher erlebt hat,
dass man wie runterkommt.
Die wilden Zeiten
hat man hinter sich.
Jetzt baut man sich das Fundament
mit den Kindern zu einem Haus auf.
Also für mich heisst das Sicherheit,
nicht Instabilität.
Kindern gibt man Geborgenheit.
Die Eltern bieten eine Schutzhülle.
Ende 2018
reiste seine Frau mit den Kindern -
damals vier und zwei Jahre alt -
nach Russland,
angeblich ferienhalber.
Der Anfang eines Albtraums.
In mir drin ist so eine Unruhe.
Ich kann eine halbe Stunde lesen,
aber dann kribbelt es wieder.
Wenn man Zeit zum Überlegen hat ...
In einsamen Momenten
denkt man wirklich:
"Muss mir das passieren?"
Es ist eine Apokalypse, total.
So kann man das sagen.
Die Kinder seien hauptsächlich
vom Vater betreut worden,
werden später
verschiedene Zeugen aussagen.
Frau und Mann werden angehört,
E-Mails und Chatverläufe ausgewertet.
Daraus ergibt sich ein Gesamtbild
für das Bezirksgericht Dietikon.
Es kommt 2019 zum Schluss,
dass die Mutter
"die Kinder als Druckmittel"
gegen den Vater einsetzen wolle.
Sie sei massgeblich "von
egoistischen Motiven angetrieben"
und unterwerfe "das Kindeswohl
ihren eigenen Interessen".
Mithin sei ihre "Erziehungsfähigkeit
in Abrede zu stellen".
Der Uetliberg liegt direkt
vor Schlagmüllers Haustür.
Hier war er regelmässig
mit seinen Söhnen unterwegs.
Es ist nicht ganz einfach.
Das ist ein schwieriger Moment.
Einfach sehr emotional.
* Kinderlachen *
Wie ist das für Sie,
wenn Sie all die Familien sehen?
Es ist ein Verdrängungsprozess.
Der funktioniert als Automatismus.
Wenn man das nicht bewältigen kann,
fällt man in ein Loch rein.
Tag für Tag
versucht er zu verdrängen,
dass seine Kinder plötzlich komplett
aus seinem Leben verschwunden sind
und er keine Ahnung hat,
wie es ihnen geht.
In die Höhe zu gehen,
gibt einem Auftrieb.
Das war auch letztes Jahr so.
Das hielt mich bei der Stange.
Laut Gericht brachte er die Kinder
jeweils vor der Arbeit in die Krippe,
wo er sie nach seinem Feierabend
wieder abholte.
Er ass mit ihnen, spielte mit ihnen,
brachte sie ins Bett.
Kurz:
Die Betreuung der Kinder im Alltag
habe hauptsächlich er übernommen,
sofern sie nicht durch Drittpersonen
in der Krippe betreut worden seien.
Die Mutter habe wenig Interesse
an den Buben gezeigt,
stellte das Gericht fest.
Es sprach mich im Dorf mal ein
Passant, der mich kennt, darauf an,
dass man mich nur alleine sehe,
ob ich alleinerziehend sei.
Das ist schon speziell,
wenn das Umfeld das wahrnimmt.
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Man sucht dann diese Ausflüchte.
Man kaschiert seine Lebenssituation
natürlich, das ist klar.
Umso bitterer ist es,
dass er, der 100 % arbeitete
und daneben
alles für seine Kinder tat,
nun alleine dasteht.
Denken Sie, dass wir in einem Jahr
mit Ihren Jungs hier oben sind?
Das wäre natürlich der Hammer,
wenn wir das schaffen würden.
Genau.
Ist das Ihre Hoffnung?
- Die grosse Hoffnung, genau.
In seiner Verzweiflung
wandte er sich an Jürg Jordi,
einen
pensionierten Kantonspolizisten,
der heute als Privatermittler
tätig ist
und die Fährte der verschwundenen
Kinder aufgenommen hat.
Im Moment haben wir News -
nicht unbedingt gute.
Wir hatten die Mutter mit ihren
Kindern ziemlich lange im Blickfeld.
Wir wussten, wo sie sich aufhält.
Und jetzt hat sie den Wohnort
ziemlich unverhofft ...
... verlassen und ist zurzeit mit
den Kindern spurlos verschwunden.
Gehen Sie davon aus,
dass Sie sie wieder finden?
Ja, ich bin überzeugt davon,
dass wir sie wiederfinden werden.
Im Moment ist es schwierig,
darüber eine Aussage zu machen.
Aber wir werden
verschiedene Massnahmen ergreifen,
auch technischer Art.
Wir werden auch weitere Ermittlungen
vor Ort anstellen.
Ich bin da guter Dinge,
dass wir die Frau,
die Mutter mit ihren Kindern,
wiederfinden werden.
Peter Schlagmüller
muss derweil versuchen,
im Alltag weiter zu funktionieren,
optimistisch zu bleiben
und Geduld zu haben.
Nach über einem Jahr
ohne Kontakt zu seinen Kindern
fällt ihm das zusehends schwerer.
Situationen, in denen es Kinder
um mich herum hat ...
... sind schwierig.
Ich habe viele Kinder
in meinem Umfeld.
Sie kennen mich
und kommen im Dorf auf mich zu.
Da gibt es Momente,
in denen stark Parallelen
zu meinen Kindern aufkommen.
Das ist dann schon verdammt hart.
Was fühlen Sie dann?
Dann wird das Rad der Zeit
sozusagen zurückgedreht.
Dann lebe ich
in den Jahren 2016 bis 2018.
Müssen Sie dann weg?
Halten Sie das nicht aus?
Genau, da muss ich Gegensteuer
geben, sonst kommt es nicht gut.
Privatermittler Jürg Jordi
hat inzwischen ein ganzes Dossier
zum Fall Schlagmüller
zusammengestellt,
um die Spur der Kinder und der Frau
wiederzufinden.
Konkret ...
... geht es darum
bzw. hat sich jetzt ergeben,
dass wir gewisse Aufenthaltsorte
der Mutter der Ex-Frau haben.
Wir kennen ihre Adresse.
Wir haben ihre Telefonnummer.
Wir haben auch Kontakte der Ex-Frau,
als sie in der Schweiz wohnte,
die auch weiter nach Russland
führen.
All das werten wir jetzt
natürlich aus und überprüfen,
ob die Ex-Frau weiterhin mit
diesen Leuten in Verbindung steht.
Das gäbe uns wiederum einen Anhalts-
punkt für ihren Aufenthaltsort.
Dieses Dossier hat er
auf Russisch übersetzen lassen,
denn er arbeitet nun
mit russischen Ermittlern zusammen
und möchte bald selber
nach Russland reisen.
Doch dann kommt das Coronavirus
und legt
den internationalen Flugverkehr lahm.
Russland reagiert u.a. mit teilweise
strengen Ausgangsbeschränkungen.
Ermittlungen vor Ort müssen auf
unbestimmte Zeit verschoben werden.
Eine Hiobsbotschaft
für Peter Schlagmüller,
den das Virus ins Homeoffice zwingt.
Ein Wiedersehen mit seinen Kindern
ist in weite Ferne gerückt.
Seit dem letzten Mal
hat sich durch das Coronavirus,
durch die weltweite Pandemie ...
... die Gemütslage bei mir
extrem verschlechtert.
Anfänglich.
Aber bald kam wieder die Einsicht,
dass ich nichts verändern kann.
Es liegt nicht in meiner Hand.
Es wird weitergekämpft,
damit ich meine Jungs zurückkriege.
Das hat dann überwogen.
Dennoch muss man sagen, dass es ...
... schon zermürbend ist, das Ganze.
Man hat keinen Zeithorizont,
wann der Erfolg
endlich da sein wird.
Es vergehen gut fünf Monate
ohne Fortschritte.
Und plötzlich
geht alles ganz schnell.
November 2020.
Peter Schlagmüller befindet sich
in Begleitung
eines russischen "Reporter"-Kollegen
auf dem Weg nach St. Petersburg -
zu einem Gerichtstermin.
Ich hoffe schwer, dass ich
meine Kinder nach bald zwei Jahren
wiedersehen und umarmen kann.
Das ist mein innigster Wunsch.
Erreichen will er das
mithilfe des sog. Haager Abkommens,
das auch Russland unterzeichnet hat.
Dieses soll die sofortige Rückgabe
widerrechtlich
in einen Vertragsstaat verbrachter
oder dort zurückgehaltener Kinder
sicherstellen.
Dass seine Kinder Ende 2018
widerrechtlich nach Russland gebracht
und seither
dort zurückgehalten werden,
hat ein Schweizer Gericht
so festgestellt.
Die grosse Frage ist nun: Sieht es
ein russisches Gericht gleich
und zwingt die Mutter dazu,
die Kinder herauszugeben?
Ich vertraue darauf,
dass Russland ehrlich entscheidet,
nicht voreingenommen
zugunsten der Mutter.
Ähm ...
Sie sollen die Lage einfach authen-
tisch einschätzen und entscheiden -
zum Wohle der Kinder.
Russische Anwälte haben
diese Verhandlung für ihn erreicht.
Seine Frau
wurde inzwischen gefunden -
allerdings nicht
durch den Privatermittler,
sondern
durch die russischen Behörden.
Sie wurde für heute vorgeladen,
taucht aber nicht auf,
denn sie sei am Coronavirus erkrankt,
heisst es.
Es ist eine kurze Verhandlung
mit folgendem Fazit:
Enttäuschend
für einen Schweizer Vater.
Ich fühle momentan ...
... ziemlich viel Leere,
sagen wir es mal so.
Ausser Spesen
einmal mehr nichts gewesen.
Zu einem Gespräch mit seiner Frau
kommt es nicht.
Die Geschenke,
die er für die Kinder mitbrachte,
kann er wieder mit nach Hause nehmen.
Das Gerichtsurteil aus der Schweiz,
das ihm in allen Punkten recht gab,
ist hier wertlos.
Die Kinder, beide
russisch-schweizerische Doppelbürger,
sollen nach rund zwei Jahren
nicht aus ihrer Lebenssituation
herausgerissen werden,
argumentiert das russische Gericht.
Und dann das:
Plötzlich eine SMS seiner Frau -
mit sehr förmlicher Anrede.
"Sehr geehrter Herr Schlagmüller,
ich bin bereit,
Frieden zu unterschreiben."
"Mit Alimenten und Besuchsterminen."
"Wo findet das Treffen statt?"
Ich bin überrascht.
Ich bin total überrascht,
dass sie schreibt.
Sie hat einen Skype-Account
geöffnet, nach eineinhalb Jahren.
What is she doing?
She refused.
Es ist ein schwieriger Moment jetzt.
Sie will mich nur
um den Finger wickeln.
Das ist ihre Taktik.
Heute. Cegodnya.
Gut.
Ja, heute.
Peter Schlagmüller
macht sich sogleich
auf den Weg
zum vereinbarten Treffpunkt.
Puh!
Dort will er nicht nur seine Frau,
sondern v.a. seine Kinder
endlich wiedersehen.
Zuerst möchte ich sie umarmen ...
... und sagen,
dass ich sie ganz fest lieb habe.
Den Rest werden wir sehen.
Trotz angeblicher COVID-Erkrankung
taucht seine Frau auf -
alleine.
Der russische "Reporter"-Kollege
beobachtet vom Nebentisch aus
eine emotionale Begrüssung
und ein kurzes Treffen.
Sie sieht nur eine Möglichkeit,
gemeinsam einen Weg zu beschreiten:
Wenn sie eine
unterzeichnete Vereinbarung hat,
dass sie von mir Geld erhält.
Sonst funktioniert es nicht
mit den Kindern.
Das finde ich absolut scheusslich.
* Fröhliche, russische Musik *
Es ist
eine juristische Pattsituation:
Schlagmüller hat in der Schweiz
recht bekommen,
seine Frau in Russland.
Nun müssen die beiden
wohl oder übel versuchen,
sich irgendwie zu finden -
v.a. auch in finanzieller Hinsicht.
Am nächsten Morgen hat sich die
Situation bereits wieder verändert.
Seine Frau
habe sich nun doch bereit erklärt,
ihm ein Wiedersehen mit den Kindern
zu ermöglichen -
und zwar schon heute.
Ich denke, nach der
überraschenden Begegnung gestern ...
... die sehr emotional war, hat das
auch bei ihr Spuren hinterlassen
und Anlass zu Gedanken gegeben.
Und ja, ich glaube ...
... wichtig ist,
dass wir den Fokus nicht verlieren,
nämlich das Kindeswohl.
Ob das Treffen mit seinen Söhnen
wirklich stattfinden wird,
ist unklar.
Schlagmüller rechnet mit allem.
Und wenn es zum Wiedersehen kommt:
Wie werden die Kinder reagieren?
Immerhin haben ihn
der inzwischen Vier- und Sechsjährige
seit zwei Jahren nicht mehr gesehen.
Es ist schon ein spezielles Gefühl,
das muss man sagen.
Mal schauen ...
... ob sie mich noch kennen.
Treffpunkt ist die Schule der Kinder.
Der russische "Reporter"-Kollege
filmt vom Auto aus,
wie es schliesslich tatsächlich zum
lange ersehnten Wiedersehen kommt.
Am nächsten Morgen:
Schlagmüller meldet sich per SMS.
Er habe letzte Nacht in der Wohnung
seiner Frau schlafen dürfen -
mit den Kindern in den Armen.
Heute sei er den ganzen Tag
mit ihnen unterwegs.
Er sei überglücklich.
Nachdem er
in sein Hotel zurückgekehrt ist,
treffen wir ihn wieder.
Yes, that's really amazing.
Den Kindern gehe es gut.
Das Eis sei schnell gebrochen.
Obwohl die Buben
nur noch Russisch sprechen.
* Die Kinder
unterhalten sich auf Russisch. *
Süss. Total süss.
They were really happy to see me.
Look at this. So nice.
Wir sprechen jetzt
von einer komfortablen Ausgangslage.
Es ist völlig deeskaliert.
Die Mutter signalisiert plötzlich
auch weiterhin
regelmässigen Kontakt.
Die Social-Media-Kontakte
sind plötzlich wieder offen.
Sie blockiert nichts mehr.
Ich bin erstaunt und frage mich,
ob es so weitergeht.
Es wäre schön, wenn wir wöchentlich
zwei-, dreimal über WhatsApp
Videocalls führen könnten.
Das wäre super.
Weihnachten 2020.
Bei Peter Schlagmüller
gibt es Spaghetti und Crevetten.
Er feiert wieder alleine.
Die Kinder
hat er nicht zurückbekommen.
Trotzdem
sind es schöne Festtage für ihn,
denn er hat nun regelmässige
Videotelefonate mit seinen Söhnen.
Irgendwann
hat es plötzlich wieder geklappt.
Der Kanal war offen.
Man konnte plötzlich wieder reden.
Logischerweise stecken dann auch die
pekuniären Forderungen dahinter -
für Unterhalt und Alimente.
In meinem Fall
ist das auch die Chance,
eine tragfähige Lösung hinzukriegen.
Gut.
Offen ist,
wie viel Geld fliessen muss,
damit der Kontakt bestehen bleibt.
Schlagmüller ist sicher,
dass man sich finden wird -
irgendwie und irgendwann -
im Interesse der Kinder.
Die Perspektive heisst,
den Zustand konsolidieren,
der sich jetzt ergeben hat.
Weiter darauf aufbauen und festigen.
Die Beziehung zur Gegenseite ...
... mütterlicherseits,
aufrechterhalten.
Die Kinder weiterhin so ...
... behandeln, wie sie sich das
gewohnt sind mit dem Papi.
Einfach nichts verändern.
Die Beziehung mit der richtigen
Weit- und Vorsicht aufrechterhalten.
Was er noch nicht ahnt: Schon bald
wird wieder alles anders sein.
Flughafen St. Petersburg,
Ende Januar 2021.
Schlagmüller ist zurück in Russland
und hat Neuigkeiten.
Nichts Positives.
Sie hat wieder komplett zugemacht.
Sie verwehrt den Zugang wieder.
Sie fordert nur Geld.
Geld für keine Gegenleistung.
Der Vater
darf seine Kinder nicht sehen.
Es ist einfach unmenschlich.
Ja, jetzt bin ich wieder hier.
Ich bin wieder hier.
Ob er seine Geschenke übergeben kann,
ist unklar.
Diese ...
Sie mögen Biberli sehr gerne.
Schweizer Biberli.
Dann für die Bildung.
René geht schon bald in die Schule.
Das ist ein Buch, in dem er
seine Freunde eintragen kann,
was sie miteinander machen.
Und ein Malbuch über die Schweiz.
Vielleicht besuchen sie mich ja mal.
Ja, das wär's.
Keine Antwort. Nichts.
Nichts.
Hm. Mein Gott, ey.
Weil er ihren Geldforderungen
nicht nachgekommen ist,
hat seine Frau wieder jeglichen
Kontakt zu den Kindern unterbunden.
Schlagmüller
will trotzdem vorbeigehen,
auch wenn er ausdrücklich
unerwünscht ist.
Ein paar Stunden später
meldet er sich per Telefon:
Er habe seine Kinder
auf dem Spielplatz angetroffen.
Dann sei seine Frau aufgetaucht und
habe sie mit in die Wohnung genommen.
Drinnen hätten die Kinder geweint,
draussen habe er geweint.
Am nächsten Morgen
hat er ein Hotel direkt
neben der Schule der Kinder bezogen,
um ihnen wenigstens so
nahe sein zu können.
Die gestrigen Ereignisse
hätten ihn traumatisiert -
v.a. die weinenden Kinder,
die versucht hätten, zu schlichten.
That was ...
... very special.
Jetzt bin ich irgendwie leer.
Ich bin so erschöpft. Ich habe ...
... so viel geweint.
Das ist ganz speziell.
Jetzt bin ich wieder gefasst,
aber eigentlich total leer
und frustriert.
Ich muss weiterkämpfen
für meine Jungs.
Schlagmüller will
einen letzten Versuch unternehmen,
mit seiner Frau
ins Gespräch zu kommen.
Darum kehrt er dorthin zurück,
wo er gestern hemmungslos weinte -
ohne damit etwas erreicht zu haben.
Hier wohnen sie.
Are you coming?
I don't know.
Ich glaube, jemand ist da,
aber sie macht nicht auf.
Gehen wir wieder runter.
Ich glaube, man kann das
für dieses Wochenende abschliessen.
Ich denke, man kann das ...
... als erledigt betrachten.
Gut zwei Monate später.
Eine Mediation, für die er mehrmals
nach Russland reiste,
sei gescheitert,
weil die finanziellen Forderungen
immer exorbitanter geworden seien.
Der Kontakt zu den Kindern
ist abgebrochen.
Ich habe einen riesigen Kreis
gedreht.
Aber das Endziel, als Vater in Würde
an meine Kinder ranzukommen ...
Was die zwei Buben verdient hätten,
habe ich bis jetzt nicht erreicht,
obwohl ich alles daran gesetzt habe.
Das ist extrem frustrierend.
Mit der Frage,
was in einer so hoffnungslosen
Situation das Beste für Kinder ist,
ist er im Internet auf die Stiftung
für Kinder in der Schweiz gestossen.
Mit Romeo Maggi, dem Gründer,
hat sich ein Austausch entwickelt.
Das erste persönliche Treffen findet
im Stiftungssitz in Hergiswil statt.
Für Schlagmüller
der letzte Strohhalm,
nachdem er seine juristischen
Möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft hat.
Ich glaube, jede aggressive Form,
die man zum Einsatz bringen möchte,
wäre kontraproduktiv für Sie -
und auch für die Kinder,
da bin ich überzeugt.
Das Gefährliche ist ja immer,
dass Kinder in solchen Streitereien
instrumentalisiert werden.
Und davon
können sie ein Trauma davontragen,
das sie entweder
direkt zum Ausdruck bringen
oder das sich erst später zeigt.
Das muss man einfach vermeiden.
Das kann auch bedeuten,
zu akzeptieren,
dass man als Vater viel zahlen soll,
aber die Kinder kaum sehen darf.
Das haben wir in der Schweiz
sehr oft:
Väter,
die eine Art Kindesentzug haben.
Die daran verzweifeln.
Die sich dann sozial zurückziehen
und nicht mehr
ans Rechtssystem glauben.
Da fällt alles über einem zusammen.
Da ist ganz wichtig,
dass man in solchen Fällen eine
Bezugsperson hat, einen Fachmann.
Wir haben fantastische Leute
in der Schweiz,
die das professionell
begleiten können und aufzeigen,
dass man aus der Situation
rauskommen kann.
Man muss sein Mindset verändern
und auch wieder sagen,
was sein Ziel ist.
Die Kinder werden älter
und man will einfach als Vater -
oder als Mutter - zeigen,
dass man seine Verantwortung,
so gut es ging, gelebt hat,
und dass man anständig
und korrekt war.
Das Wichtigste ist, dass ich
bei der Lösungsfindung bleibe
und den Fokus nicht verliere.
Immer nach vorne schaue.
Aber ja,
die Monate und Jahre verstreichen.
Ich denke schon immer mal wieder:
"Verdammt noch mal,
jetzt war ich mal näher dran!"
Aber es wendet sich
einfach nie zum Guten.
"Was willst du da
noch weitermachen?"
Aber der unbändige Wille,
den ich habe,
für meine Kinder da zu sein,
obsiegt dann schlussendlich.
Was in fünf Jahren sein wird,
ob wir dann immer noch
an einem ähnlichen Punkt stehen ...
Das hoffe ich nicht.
Aber im Worst-Case-Szenario
weiss man ja nie.
Vielleicht dauert es
doch noch fast eine Ewigkeit.
Aber ich darf nicht daran denken,
sonst zieht mich das runter.
Das ist nicht das Ziel.
Viel Zeit und viele Tränen
hat ihn der mehr als zweijährige
Kampf um seine Kinder gekostet -
aber auch viel Geld:
bisher rund 250'000 Fr.
Ein Happy End ist nicht in Sicht.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021